what were you thinking who jumps in
front of a tie on a joyride
seriously tell me about i'm sorry well
hey
it's not that big of a problem right
can't you just use your powers to fix
your car and house faster
of course but fixing them by hand kills
time and gives me something to gripe
about i mean
it's something i enjoy because i believe
in hard work yeah
but i digress why are you here goku what
what do you think don't talk with your
mouth full it's rude and it's a choking
hazard
i'm stuffed don't worry there's no
trouble
i came here to train a bit that's all
your world's gravity is 10 times
stronger than earth's remember
i can't think of a better place in the
universe to build some serious muscle
uh hmm you don't sound happy
of course i'm not why would i be happy
that hussein is using my sacred world as
his own workout gym and let me guess
you'll want room and board with that too
yeah sure that sounds great come on king
kai you act like we're not pals or
something
hey maybe you forgot because of my
disarming sense of humor but i have a
pretty major deal
i'm way higher than a guardian then you
wouldn't have talked to tommy like this
i'm gonna jump to it all right hey
man this feels great nothing better than
training